this is from the daily wire
you've really seen a city that used to
be
one of the best in the country
you've just seen it become hollowed out
and it's a direct result of leftist
policy and leftist ideology
I never thought California license plate
grown up in Florida then I become
governor
we have Californians flooding leaving
San Francisco to go to Miami and other
places
it was intolerable to live in this area
because they don't care about crime they
don't care about homelessness
no one wants to live under those
circumstances how you doing it's
pleasure to me good to see you man your
city police yes how long have you been
doing it uh 17 years God bless you man
you got your work cut out for you here
how you doing buddy hey thanks so much
for your service good luck we appreciate
you guys you guys deserve better support
I mean it's not it's unacceptable that
you're going out there risking your life
you can apprehend someone and they just
let them go I mean it's absurd so yeah
we appreciate it sir so yeah yeah thank
you great to see you guys what uh
Biden's allowed to happen at the border
is killing Americans with the fentanyl
our view in Florida is we're going to
help at the border we're doing that
we're not a sanctuary State we've banned
Sanctuary cities if you bring in
illegals from the border and smuggle
into Florida we're gonna hold you
accountable for doing that as president
we'll crack down on Sanctuary cities
Nationwide and Sanctuary States we can
withhold funding or whatever we'll pull
every lever that we have and we'll
Marshal all the assets military uh
civilian you name it this has gone on
for decades and yet it's never been
fixed we'll bring it to a conclusion
what do I always say what did I say
earlier it doesn't have to be this way
and now the vision is starting to
present itself we can have Law and Order
why is it that Florida does not have
cities that look like San Francisco why
is it that one day on this show what was
it about five months ago I was going
through the numbers of of homeless in
all of these crazy blue cities I think
it was 70 000 in Los Angeles 40 000 in
San Francisco although per capita in San
Francisco it's a much smaller city than
Los Angeles so it seems like it's a lot
more it feels like it's a lot more and
literally as I was doing it my phone lit
up and it was the freaking mayor of
Miami and he's like we have 280 homeless
people here and I'm working on it stay
tuned like we we believe in Law and
Order here we we believe that you should
not allow endless amounts of illegal
immigrants and drugs and all of those
things to have our cities and our towns
destroyed and that is what we are are
trying to now blueprint for the rest of
the country and it can happen and I'm
telling you guys it's connected to what
happened today this this Supreme Court
thing is absolutely huge we will get rid
of racism we will get rid of the people
who think we should not have a border
and everything else and the people who
think we should not arrest criminals and
you should be allowed to just dump drugs
on our streets and everything else
[Music]
foreign